الانسان يتاثر بكل شيء حوله فامورا بسيطه
من شانها ان تغير مزاجه اما للافضل او
للاسود يعتبر ديكور المنزل احد الوسائل
القادره على تغيير مزاجنا فهو المعالج
الخفي لتغيير المزاج من الكابه الى
السعاده فقد اثبتت دراسات بحسب موقع هلس
بوليسي انا ديكور قابل على تغيير مزاج
والمتحكم بما نشعر به من احاسيس مثل
السعاده او الاكتئاب او الحزن او
الرومانسيه والعوده الى المنزل ثاني
الراحه ليس جسديه فقط نفسيه ايضا ولذلك
فمن الضروري ان يهتم اصحاب البيت في توفير
عناصر الراحه والطاقه الايجابيه عند
اختيار ديكور البيت عن بلا طرق عديده منها
كيفيه تنسيق الاثاث واختيار الالوان
المناسبه واستغلال المساحات يصبح البيت
مصدرالصحه النفسيه والطاقه الايجابيه
[موسيقى]
طيب الاستديم المختصه في تصميم الديكور
المنزلي نغمه
بالكثير من الديكور بالكثير من الزينات
الى اي مدى بالفعل هذه الامور تؤثر على
نفسيتنا وسعادتنا هي لا تاثير كبير يعني
حتى الدراسات مؤخرا اثبتت ان الديكور
المنزلي الداخلي باثر كثير على الحاله
النفسيه والحاله المزاجيه وكمان بياثر على
بنحس بايه يعني ممكن يخلينا نحس باكتئاب
او بسعاده او حتى بالرومانسيه اوقات لو
الديكور معمول مضبوط ومراعين في كل
التفاصيل والعناصر اللي بتاثر على الحاله
النفسيه طب يعني مرات بيقولوا لك اشياء
صغيره بتحول حياتك للافضل او للاسوء انا
بدي اشوف شو اللي ممكن يحول حياتي للسعاده
والرومانسيه في البيت في حاجات كثير صغيره
بسيطه وفي منها حاجات كثير مش مكلفه كمان
يعني
النظافه والترتيب النظام يعني النظافه
والترتيب بتاثر كثير على الراحه النفسيه
دي اول حاجه يعني من غير لسه ما دخلناش في
عناصر ثانيه اه الاضاءه اا الاضاءه تكون
اضاءه مضبوطه يعني نحاول دائما يكون في
اضاءه طبيعيه في البيت همم تدخل البيت همم
طول اليوم همم ولو ما فيش اضاءه طبيعيه
نحاول نعمل توازن بين الاضاءه الصفراء
والاضاءه البيضاء بحيث انها تدينا الاضاءه
همم قريبه اضاءه الشمس احلى الصفراء
الصفراء طول الوقت لو صفره بس كمان لا في
درجه بين الاصفر والابيض دي بتبقى انسب
درجه همم للاضاءه في البيت وحسب مكانها
كمان بتفرق ال- همم النباتات والزهور كمان
بتفرق كثير جدا في الحاله النفسيه همم
بشكل عام يعني للناس احساسه تتحسس ان
الواحد باللي راحه وبالطبيعه على طول
الوقت فادي كمان ساعه كثير ففي حاجات يعني
معينه بسيطه كده لو الناس التزمت انها
تعملها او تخلي بالها منها هتفرق كثير
هتخلي في اخر البيت همم مريح همم وحبه
انها ترجع بيتها عشان تستريح اه حلو طيب
احنا راح نشوف كمان فيديو هلا اييه عم
نشوفه نحنا هلا
نغمه كيف طريقه الترتيب بدها مثلا
بيبقى مهم قوي ان احنا نعمل مكان في البيت
كورنر للقهوه او للشاي ويكون عاملينه
بطريقه مريحه وفي نفس الشكل وكمان يفتح
النفس او شكله مرتب وشكله جميل وبنقدر
نعمل فيه ديكورات كمان تخليه شكله جمال
اكثر فدي مثلا ده كونر انا كنت عاملاه زي
نموذج يعني كوفي كورنر يكون مريح وفي نفس
الوقت شكله همم منظم ومرتب وفيه كل
احتياجاتنا احنا نعمل القهوه
مع القهوه او حتى الاطباق الصغيره اللي
هنستخدمها بحس ان انت مش هتحتاجي ان انت
تروحي اي مكان ثاني هي المكان ده مخصص
للقهوه بكل همم
مشتملاتها يعني فا- همم دي كمان كورنر من
الحاجات المهمه تكون موجوده في كل بيت همم
بتفرق كثير في همم كمان بالسعاده والراحه
ان الحاجه اللي انا باحبها موجوده طول
الوقت واقدر اعملها بكل سهوله نغم مع عصير
السرعه تراجع الثقافه الاستقبال اليوم الى
متى الاستقبال استقبال الضيوف مهمله راحت
لنا نفسيه وما هي نصائح للديكور في حال
الاستقرار استقبال استضافه الناس اا هو ده
اساسا ده مين اللي انا بتكلم عليه كمان في
البيت عندي انه اا اللي هوستنج تيبس او
ايه اللي بنقدر نعمله عشان نستضيف الناس
او اصحابنا او اهلنا في بيوتنا بطريقه
تكون بالنسبه لنا مريحه وكمان مريحه
بالنسبه كمان للضيوفنا فانا دائما باشوف
انه يعني مثلا ده ترتيب بوفيه انا باشوف
فكره في العزائم همم انسب بكثير من ان
احنا نبقى قاعدين في نفس المكان في مكان
ثابت على السفره فدي بتدي حوريه الحركه
شويه للناس همم
حسبي احراج كمان لما بيكون كبير بتبقى
غصبا عنك عن عدد كراسي السفر فطبيعي ان
انت لازم هتعملي هتروحي الاوبشن الثاني
اللي هو ان انت تعمليه بوفيه اللي هو
العدد كبير يعني وبالعكس انا باشوفه فيها
راحه للناس اكثر لانه بيختار اللي هو
عايزه بياخذ من ده او من ده او ما بيبقى
وبيتحرك بحريه اكثر
فده مثلا ديكور ثاني همم الكوفي تابل في
اوضه ال- حقنه الليفنج اوضه همم
كمان انه يكون في كل همم يعني كل مكان في
البيت يكون فيه لمسه جماليه او فيه ديكور
بسيط وكمان بيكون مناسب يعني ده انا كنت
عاملاه والناس
كل دي حاجات بتفرق همم يعني همم في الروح
العمل البيت ويروح الضيوف اللي داخله كمان
البيت بتحس انها داخله في مكان مريح قوي
طيب والعفش يعني نركز اكثر على الوان شو
العفش الالوان انا بشوف ان الالوان
الاحاديه اكثر الوان بتبقى مناسبه وبتقدري
تركبي عليها اي الوان ثانيه بارجه في
السيزون ان انت تجيبيها كوشينز مثلا او
تبقى
اباجوره باللون طالع دارج فانا بشوف
الالوان الاحاديه بيقدر يركب عليها اي
الوان ثانيه
وبتبقى مريحه للعين اكثر من الالوان
الصرخه او الالوان
القويه الالوان القويه كمان بتبقى شويه
بتحدك في تركيب الالوان مع بعض بالنسبه
همم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا